[Music]
welcome to Samuel Leeds podcast on this
week's episode we talk influences
investing and inspiration so what if
you've been up to this week this week
has been crazy busy week so we met up
with Patricia bright yeah which was
awesome yeah and you kind of made that
happen a little bit solo so you know
it's so call me in all these great
people and I've been training I've been
spending some time at home I've been
going crazy about some of the bats in
the castle which is been mad but we've
just had our license they've given us a
license to be able to do work so the
bats are all sorted the bats are housed
the bats the mats are good so just
juggling you know juggling business and
media and property and training I've
been in the office loads as you probably
picked up just because I can't keep away
I love the birds what happened why was
everyone clapping randomly we had
Employee of the Month was announced who
was it so it's a massive shout out to
armored finance money man yeah you need
to have a good money man yeah you need
to have a good money man so yeah just a
great week so cool so it talks to me a
little bit about influences and you know
Patricia Brant and what you're doing
with people at the minute so I'm really
excited because I've just basically
there's this person in our team who's
amazing who I've just kind of made
talent manager so so I don't know
exactly what they're going to be doing
but they're going to be working
specifically with booking me speaking
engagements and also working with
influencers but you can tell us more
because obviously you're a person okay
yes so basically I'm gonna be doing
talent management and what that involves
is basically anyone that's on Samuels
channel and doing contracts like talking
to them and that includes winners on a
Wednesday for the success students and
that includes influencers that includes
experts that we might get on the channel
do you know what as well I love that
you've almost created a community with
the windows Wednesday people yeah so now
in winners Wednesday coming on it's not
like they just come in on the show
sharing their story great and obviously
they get exposure off that and it's
awesome but now it's like you're gonna
be doing dinners winners Wednesday
dinner yeah winners Wednesday Facebook
group winners Wednesday VIP what's up
hey what's up like that's just awesome
because because I think I hold business
philosophy is you make one move we make
ten and when people work hard enough to
be able to come on winners Wednesday
meaning they're financially free all
over their life dramatically changed
through property as a result of our
training I mean geez man we want to
celebrate that yeah celebrate that like
crazy
definitely yeah we're making it more so
it's like it's always like its own
little company winners ones that they
want to make it yeah so it's like yeah
it's like the top enterprise yeah so
it's like the top people in the company
that's got his own CRM system yeah
meaning what the CRM stand for like
client relationship yeah yeah you are
my talent CRM system no but for sure
and the thing is this role that you're
doing is kind of like what I did
informally before but didn't have the
time to really do and I'd be getting to
speak people saying oh something can you
come and speak at this event or I've
been having so many people all over the
world trying to book me to go and speak
at their events or run stuff or feature
on their YouTube channel and it's not
that in the past I've not wanted to I've
really wanted to but I just never
haven't physically either had the time
or I haven't even seen the message what
about tell tell them about what happened
on Instagram when you were on the
unfiltered messages well no not
necessarily him but just in general so
we have obviously you'll have like
message requests off people maybe you're
not followed no I'm not following so I
don't see it yes so you won't see it and
on there we'll have like loads of
footballers like influences all these
people reaching out and the messages
just aren't read so I don't even see
them so if you are a celebrity or an
influencer or just a regular person
who's awesome and you've been messaging
me on Instagram and I've not been
responding it's not because I'm not I'm
ignoring you it's because I literally
haven't even seen the messages I didn't
even know that folder existed and even
and you were there we were in that we
were driving and you were just curtly
scrolling through going oh this person
and it was like all these famous people
and on this person and this blues [ __ ]
this person and I'm just like I can't
believe I've blanked these people and
she don't makes it worse after 30 days
it deletes the message yeah yeah so we
only spotted this last month imagine how
many people have messaged us and now
their message is gone and we don't ever
know yep terrible it's crazy but we're
on it now
and yeah well definitely be getting back
to people more and working with you've
worked with Patricia bright yeah you've
worked with James Caan yeah that was
cool that was so cool did you like me
and James yeah what was James like in
compared to what you thought he'd be
like I thought it would be a lot more
Stern like a comb-over when I was
setting up they're like cameras and he
was just making funny faces and yeah he
just seems super alive cuz he's like a
dragon and Draco was a dragon on
Dragon's Den and yeah you'd think he'd
be really like was the word hard loses
like he's actually such a nice guy
so cool but so smart yeah it was
incredible to like hear everything he's
done yeah like so much charity work as
well in and then also of I don't know
how involved you where did you come to
the Robert Kiyosaki dinner I didn't I
was before before my time are you gonna
come to me but Grant Cardone in Miami at
some point I would love to I'm sure you
will
Nick Smith is on the podcast about you
may might I'm Nick's men Mitnick Nick's
met everybody Nick Meg Gary Vaynerchuk
yeah
and Grant Cardone Emilia you yeah you've
got a lot of catching up I get the next
date yeah Nix Nix the og a Knicks the
Knicks the the first person ever to join
the media team yeah Shantanu so looking
at this week yeah we also was this week
or last week we did your house tour that
was this week the weeks ago so that was
this week yeah like three days ago yeah
that's why you need to take a day off if
you don't take one day off a week on a
Sunday then every day rolls into one
yeah but the other house tour what about
it it was great wasn't it it was so cool
so how do you find um working with like
different people and like so for example
now that you're almost like you have
your social following and your YouTube
yeah do you get people in
do jobs and stuff and offer them like
exposure and somewhere now that's a very
secretive question that's very variance
on the podcast you know what that's so
taboo is it really interesting on that
I'll talk about this and then I can
answer the question but there was a case
a lot of influences people that have got
like 100,000 plus subscribers on YouTube
like they ask for stuff for free yeah so
but sometimes is really responded bad to
so I saw a news article of a guy to be
fair he didn't have that many followers
I think he had like thirty five thousand
followers and he was trying to stay at a
luxury hotel for free Ozark I stay for
free and oh I'll give you a shout out
and all that vlog I'll vlog must my
experience at your hotel but it was like
a small B&B type thing but it was nice
it was like a quite a posh thing I think
and they were so offended that he even
had the audacity to ask
they screenshot his message and then
like shamed him on social media and are
like saying this person's trying to eat
for free pay your way how dare you and
then they had like a they band's
influences from even ever coming to that
is like we don't want to ever deal with
it but there was so offended and I was
thinking that I get people offering to
do stuff for me for free time yeah so I
don't quite know what the etiquette is
that I'm still learning it's a
completely new field like the whole
thing is just like everyday people every
day but so a celebrity is but it's like
anyone just been answer almost make
themselves famous anyone can make
themself famous but if you haven't got
any content or charisma or persisters to
be consistent then you probably is
probably not not gonna happen
but but yeah anyone can yeah because
because everyone's in the same in the
same boat
but so to answer your question is people
say to me Samuel
I'll do your mortgages for free I just
want you to give me a shout on YouTube
or or I might say to someone hey you
know all do o me I'll do a free
mentoring session with you and because
you've got over a million subscribers
I'll do it for free but I just want you
to be able to share I want to go to
video it I know what you share
because I want to help inspire more
people I want to grow my region channel
so that whole world is something that I
do not understand I don't know the
etiquette of it I don't know if I don't
know if it that's kind of why I got you
yeah it's just kind of like value
exchange so instead of money it's a
different ball jury yeah
so I'm bartering and I've had this a lot
as well see I don't boss who people
anymore I've had people that have said
to me Samuel can I do your advanced
training for free but I'll give you this
mm-hmm
but what I've always found is those
people they don't value the training as
much because they didn't pay if you pay
then you pay attention so I don't know
what I think of bartering and luckily I
don't have to deal with that I'll let
you deal with that because you know like
same with speaking engagements people
are going to speak at their event but
for me to go and speak at an event I'm
gonna be out the office yeah I could be
literally hundreds of thousands of
pounds if I if you include travel and
this and then people will say never
never pay you a hundred thousand pounds
to come and speak it for an hour of my
event okay well I'm not forcing anybody
but I can't I can't really justify going
away from my business my office my own
events my own light to speak at your
event I can't justify it unless unless
I've got some kind of event there's got
to be value exchange so how do you kind
of manage your time then amongst things
like do you kind of prioritize things
and maybe like higher value say for
example you might be like a my YouTube
comes first like business or for well I
can ask you this question because you
kind of manage my diary a little bit you
in Valerie
yeah so Valerie's my PA you need a PA
but then you're like no a PA your talent
manager but but yes you do prioritize
stuff like that a little bit so how do i
prioritize it I guess from my point of
view is the honest answer partly I just
kind of do what I'll enjoy most
I mean I have to be honest you have to
be honest so there is a case of light
some sometimes I do things I don't enjoy
if you look at my diary and it's full
it's not filled with
stuff that I don't like doing it's full
of stuff that I really like doing so I
think that the thing that I enjoy most
Oh
the thing that I'll spend the most
common which is Mickel people doing
training finding deals making deals
happen doing YouTube videos I mean if I
don't love doing YouTube videos I'll be
miserable because I do a video every day
yeah so you've got to do what you love
doing and also I like short meetings I
don't necessarily like having like big
long discussions about stuff I just I
want to make the decision so that kind
stuff and traveling I like traveling and
I think he was either said to me oh this
came along but it's overseas so I don't
if you want me to book it or not and I
was like yo if it's overseas even better
look at ya poke me in yeah when I think
about that now I'm kind of like why'd I
even actually think that I saw it was
like a speaking can I have event you
could go to and it was in America and I
was just thinking oh I guess that won't
happen there which is quite small-minded
chance to meet Oprah Winfrey yeah it's
me Oprah but I was just thinking oh I
guess at all I'll wait till she's at or
in the UK which when you think about it
it's probably a very bad night yeah we
can't wait for Oprah to come to the UK
we'll go do yeah but well they're not
well that I say to you do you remember
you said just booked it no I said I said
for the entrepreneur a plane journeys
not not an objection yeah yes but you
can't you can't be let in plane journeys
and stuff stop yeah but as it happens I
like flying yeah so do you think it's a
luxury that you now get to do majority
of stuff that you like because no I
think everyone should do what they like
I tell I tell the same to you guys I'm
like do what you like what did I ask you
at the last at the last meeting that we
had we were in the room yeah and I want
to know what you all love doing and new
said I love putting together little
thirty-seconds thingies I don't love
making movies and trailers and stuff
like that yeah you know Nick loves being
organized and make heading up to all the
YouTube making sure everything all the
schedules are good you didn't know what
you love we're not we're not like yeah I
was like come on Amelia
when you weren't you were like just
coming out with worth like strategic
[Music]
influencer eyeballs on stuff I'm like
what the heck are you talking about lady
but but but but then we know we chatted
and you can you know we as a team
managed to pull it out of yeah yeah
because they think is I don't I don't
think anyone should do what the hell I
don't anyone should do something I hate
doing no one should do that and
financial freedom doesn't mean don't
work anymore it means you have the
choice you have the choice to do what
you enjoy doing so you can you can live
a life of freedom and actually being a
job I mean the job in a way because I'm
star still come to the office like
everyone comes to the office but it's
from choice and I think that's the same
for everyone everyone has a choice to be
here or not you ever chose to be sat on
this chair and we do this podcast you
doing what you enjoy doing so I think
when you believe that when you've got a
team of people on a mission they've got
the same values the same heart and all
doing different roles but they actually
enjoy doing yeah then that's great
because some people love doing like our
met who got one the Employee of the
Month just just just today he loves
doing finance yeah he loves it
now you probably wouldn't enjoy it so
much I don't know you know so I fill my
diary of stuff that I love but I would
also want the same for everyone in the
business really do to fill the day what
the love as long as it's also as long as
you doing stuff that's also productive
if I said I love video games and eating
then then that's then I'm not serving
anybody so how can i how can I be of
best value and be be of use in the best
way but also be doing something that I
really enjoy doing
I think dr. John Demartini says he says
how can I do what I love and get paid
handsomely to do it so it's like that
yeah yeah yeah for sure
I mean it doesn't fit because if you if
you love what you do then you'll never
work a day in your life so is that kind
of advice you would give to people when
they're looking for what to do just what
would you do if you weren't gonna be
paid yeah but it's also gotta make money
yeah so you know you've got it you've
got about to make it make money but yeah
what what what do you enjoy doing what
are you good at what you're passionate
and then you're not having to look at
the clock and think man I've got another
when I was at school I just watched the
clock all day I couldn't wait to leave
and you know I just think that sucks is
that why you're such a big advocate for
leaving school if you feel like you're
being pulled somewhere else yeah because
people go to school just because they
want to please their parents and they go
to university just because it's all
smokes and mirrors and on the basis that
they'll get a job when they leave
University a job doing something they
don't want to do like it's just a
complete hoax what why would you go to
university to study something to get a
job doing something that you don't
actually want to do to make a living why
not just figure out how to make a living
do something else yeah so yeah sure one
of the videos that we put up this week
was of you on BBC yeah tell me a little
bit more about that a BBC all the time I
was on BBC I think that was actually an
old video that was it was the one about
the financial freedom challenge yeah
okay yeah I was actually old so I up I
uploaded that this week yeah but that
was actually that happened a while ago
that was about the financial freedom
challenge when I became financially free
all over again start from scratch it
made headline news yeah so waiting to
the BBC I was on the I think it was the
six o'clock news and yeah they just
asked me you know how did you do it why
did you do it just a few minutes but hey
three minutes on on BBC six o'clock news
is kind of cool yeah so when do you
imagine doing your next FF challenge I
don't know every time I do a financial
freedom challenge I always say never
again but then within a few weeks or
months unlike each end to do it again
that's so hard though that's so hot I
don't know at some point I'm gonna fail
yeah and maybe I'm maybe I'm afraid to
fail maybe maybe be maybe it would be
good to call it a day with them I don't
know I'll probably just keep doing them
if I fail I know I'm gonna have to do it
again in the same place yeah because I'm
too competitive
is there any country you'd be scared to
in any country or you think it'd be
really hard
oh yeah there'd be some code
I mean there some could use red it's
almost illegal to make money you just
can't some countries you just cannot be
an entrepreneur and you just gotta move
yeah for sure like I mean I mean I
wouldn't go there's some countries where
I just wouldn't even try it but if I was
born in that country on move in the same
way that I moved to London you know Jim
Rohn says you can move you're not a tree
so you don't have to just [ __ ] and moan
about where you are you can actually
move because people can move and of
course there's might be some
restrictions on exactly where you can go
with visas and things like that but
where we don't really not want to go III
don't know I'd rather think about where
I'd like to go I'd like to go to Holland
Netherlands I'd like to go to Germany
I'd like to join some parts of Africa
I'd like to go back to American doing
some different states in America I've
watched the financial freedom challenge
in Australia Australia be good you've
been to Australia yes I've never been to
Australia
I just think has so much opportunity
yeah yeah especially with property like
I didn't know from a buying point of
why'd all the Australians come to the UK
there and come on my crash course
interested I guess I have to ask them
I'll have to ask them I mean obviously
they fly over don't they that's crazy
from Sydney Australia to London for two
days and then fly back it's men so I
think Australia's just one of those
places constantly growing because
there's so much land as well
everything's everything supply
everything supply and demand and if
there's I mean on the planet there's a
shortage of houses and there's an
overpopulation of people on the planet
not just in the UK but right now there's
over seven billion people in this world
and if you look at the predictions of
where it's going we're going to be
strong winter - how's everybody if you
buy property someone said don't wait to
buy property by property and wait you
know I mean of course the world is a big
place and there's some the markets are
very different in different places but
you know property investment is not just
something that's uk-based you can do it
in many many countries across the world
that's cool so do you have any plans for
any other kind of videos or have you got
anything that you like a niche that you
want to scratch of the minute in terms
of content yeah I have I got a few ideas
I don't know ever I really want to put
it out there but
well yeah always do this to me yeah okay
so I tell you something very interesting
and I've told you this story before but
I don't think I've told it on on YouTube
or on podcast before they've got like
all fail you know the crash course ago
that we okay so so for anyone that
hasn't heard the story ie most people is
some people I believe that some people
just will not be successful in life and
it's not because they can't it's just
because they won't they're there that
much fear they have that they're that
they're skeptical there that unprepared
to take action no matter what I can do
is a trainer no matter what advice I can
give them they just never gonna be
successful it's never gonna happen for
them and I believe that I can spend
three minutes with pretty much any
person on the planet and I'll be able to
tell them whether they're gonna be
successful in business or property or
not I use tell I can meet someone and
within a few minutes chat with them I
just I just know if they're gonna be
successful or not and if they're not
that can be broke as anything but I can
tell okay you're broke right now but yes
you you're gonna be successful because I
can tell from their mind I can tell from
the way their language they use the way
they speak the way they think so there's
this guy at the crash course and I sent
that he was not going to be successful
in fact probably more than since I knew
he was not gonna be successful he just
wasn't but is asking questions and he
was asking about insurances and there's
not that's just I just think in this
dude he's never gonna be successful and
I actually I basically gave him a free
house so call him story short I just I
was about to start on the paperwork and
I on a house myself and I said I'll fund
everything but you can have it towards
in your name or Institute sign and
calling story short he didn't sign it's
like and so if you won't sign when it's
handed to you on a plate and you have to
pay nothing for it even the friggin
contract is paid for and you still are
all think about oh I need to talk to my
wife I never make a decision unless I
seem I have a face-to-face first my wife
it's a little raw laugh which is stupid
rule so you're never gonna be successful
I think I'm gonna probably do the
exercise again with someone that I knows
broke minded but a film it film it
because I wish that I'd filmed Phil
because people think I can't believe
that everyone says is I would sign it I
would sign it you know Phil's in India
but I think
people wouldn't sign it I could
literally get a piece of paper with a
legally binding contract me giving away
a free house I could walk around the
streets of London and no one would sign
their damn contract and I might do that
as an experiment but if anyone has any
ideas listening to this if you want me
to do any experiments or if anyone's
listening that thinks they've got an
idea of me as a creator around property
or you know whatever it could be any
ideas financial freedom challenges or
social experiments just just let us know
and I'm crazy enough to do it because I
have the time and I have the money and I
have the inclination yeah
and I'll just go do it no definitely
we're looking to make twenty twenty make
content even more exciting yes crazy
ideas and get you everywhere so the
other day we also went to Sky Sky TV we
also do yeah yesterday days so yeah tell
me about that I love working with sky so
we are on property TV I think we've got
a weekly show on there yeah a weekly
show which is we're on Sky every week
yes week 7:00 p.m. and they wanted me it
was so popular that they wanted me to do
some stuff on a Sunday as well it wasn't
family on a Sunday but we just went in
distant we shot some stuff it was great
the studios were really good you know
what I'm so I'm so desperate for us to
try our own proper studio honestly we're
gonna look for andi'm viewings next week
for some new studios so we need one
we're gonna have one in the office but
then there's just nothing quite right
and in my house for sure we can do it we
can have a steal at my house but then
sometimes people I don't want everyone
come into my house every time we do a
video and I just we need to come up with
a solution because this where we are now
he's not good enough no Everage we need
it we need a cool studio so I came along
to the sky and I was kind of like look
in it like their setup so yeah as a
media team we're gonna make something
we're gonna make it happen so if you
could be a speaker on any stage or you
know speak and collaborate with somebody
who would it be
I mean I'm struggling to even speak on
my own stages whose stage would I love
to speak on I'm definitely gonna be
speaking to Grant Cardone
doing some stuff together he's keen to
do some stuff together we've spoke he's
awesome
I've done I've spoken on stage with
Robert Kiyosaki I really am keen and I
think I've said this to you before I'm
really keen to meet and do something
returns I love Tony Robbins Tony Robbins
is just such an amazing human being and
I'd love to do something with Tony so if
Tony is listening to this he needs to
just get his ass to London and or just
or just message me on a plane yeah maybe
we should actually reach out to Tony
because we're not I keep maybe I should
stop waiting for Tony to reach out to me
and I should just reach out to Tony I'd
love to do some of him speaking on stage
of Tony will be amazing so if you had
one place in the world right now that
you had properties if you're gonna start
investing abroad where would it be the
States yeah because there's some parts
of America which have bottomed out real
bad and property prices are cheaper
today than they were in 2008 and I
should have bottomed out there's only
one way they can go there's some parts
of the states like that where they're
also investing heavily into you know
retail and parks and cities and
buildings and I just think there's some
massive opportunities out there people
when I was in even even Philadelphia
when I was in Philadelphia that was I
was meeting people the average people
that would have bought a house for like
20 grams spent 20 on it 40 grand in
total $40,000 and then selling it for
like 80 like doubling their money and
and there's massive opportunities in the
states so I think if I wasn't gonna be
and also I might this is different
Claude I don't he's me he's been trying
to persuade me to invest with him on
some like really big deals also in
America so the problem is when you start
investing in areas where you don't know
there's always more risk yeah UK I know
it like the back of my hand you know so
it's it's much easier for me to invest
in the UK so but if I was gonna move I
would say America yeah but I think I'm
not itching to do that anytime soon I
was watching some of the older videos
before and I saw your business plan for
this year yes you know you look at how
many
you wanna buy and all that can i thing
how's it gone so far oh I was so
conservative on that video I mean that
video I've I've done that and probably
that again and again and again probably
four times what I was planning on doing
yeah killed killed that yeah killed that
I've bought so many properties this year
and didn't much better projects as well
then I was thinking but I always
publicize what I'm gonna do because I
think that some people most people want
to keep all their cards so close to
their chest they don't want to tell
people what they're about to because
they're scared people will copy them on
the obviously I want people to copy me
because then I'm a trendsetter yeah and
if people if people are copying you then
it means you're helping people it means
you're influencing people it means that
you're good it's it's it's quite
flattering if people copy you McDonald
just publish their business plan online
for all to say so all these people that
are like oh I'm scared they're gonna
copy you it's just like come on they're
never gonna copy you dick you suck
anyway your ID is terrible so if you've
got a good idea I think it's worth
sharing yeah so uh every year I always
say this is what I'm gonna do I'll tell
the world and then I'll make it happen
and then I have people like you ten
months later holding me to account and
I'm able to say I smashed it Thanks oh
so cool thank you so much for and we
talk to you today and I'll see you all
in the next podcast bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]